soixante ans après le vol de youri
gagarine dans l'espace la conquête
spatiale continue ce sont désormais les
vols habités qui intéresse les
scientifiques
mais avant de coloniser mars à
l'institut des problèmes biomédicaux de
l'académie russe des sciences
on mène des expériences sur les effets
du confinement et de l' isolement
l'un des principaux dangers des vols
spatiaux habités
bien sûr rêvais d'autres planètes n'est
pas nouveau à l'époque soviétique
les scientifiques s'étaient déjà penchés
sur le problème
après avoir envoyé le premier homme dans
l'espace
la première expérience de confinement
sur une durée d'un an s'est déroulée en
1967 dans des conditions extrêmes
mais pour la première fois dans
l'histoire la possibilité d'assurer une
activité humaine à long terme dans un
espace confiné avec régénération de
l'atmosphère et reproductions de l'eau
et de l'oxygène était confirmée
lorsqu'une personne se trouve dans un
espace confiné lorsqu'elle n'a pas la
possibilité de communiquer avec ses
proches lorsqu'il existe des conditions
de privation lié aux échanges
un arrachement au monde lorsqu'une
personne ne reçoit pas de nouvelles par
exemple elle ne peut pas sortir prendre
l'air
elle ne sait pas si c'est le jour ou la
nuit alors tous les rythmes commence à
être perturbés elle est toujours dans le
même environnement
elle commence à souffrir d'hypertension
ou d'hypotension tout cela affecte son
état psychologique
c
si certains peuvent penser qu'après
avoir subi une dizaine de confinement
lors de la pandémie ils sont prêts à
endurer sept mois de vol vers mars
ils ont tort j'étais dans un pari de
métal ses fenêtres sans huglo nous ne
pouvions pas voir la lumière du soleil
nous n'avons pas pu voir ce qu'il se
passait dehors pendant trois mois nous
n'avions pas d'internet et nous ne
pouvions pas commander de la nourriture
comme vous le faites ici
confiné vous avez une connexion internet
vous avez le service de livraison de
nourriture et tout ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez sortir les poubelles
promener votre chien sentir la lumière
du soleil sentir le vent nous bien sûr
nous ne pouvions pas un autre phénomène
majeur étudier ici à l'institut des
problèmes biomédicaux
c'est l'effet de l'apesanteur sur le
corps des cosmonautes des bénévoles
passent jusqu'à 21 jours dans un bus
noir spécial sous la surveillance des
scientifiques on va tester
très relaxant mais impossible d'imaginer
de passer ici 56 jours comble on fait
des collaborateurs soviétique de
l'institut dans les années 70 plus d'un
demi siècle d'exploration d'innombrables
expériences dans l'espace et sur terre
accompli par des amoureux du cosmos afin
de permettre à l'humanité d'approcher
d'autres planètes
aujourd'hui nous en sommes plus proches
que jamais